As another example where a control and
data plan separation comes in handy, let's look
at the security of internet backbones. Where filtering
attack traffic is a regular network management task.
Suppose that an attacker is sending lots
of traffic towards a victim. In this case
a measurement system might detect the attack, identify
the entry point, and a controller such as
the RCP might install what is called a null route to ensure
that no more traffic reaches the victim from the attacker. Two
fundamental challenges with SDN are scalability and
consistency. In an SDN a single control element
might be responsible for many forwarding elements. So control element might
be responsible for hundreds to thousands
of switches. Of course, for redundancy and
reliability, typically we want to replicate the
controller. So while the controller is logically
centralized, physically there may be many replicas.
And, in such a deployment scenario we
need to ensure that different controller replicas
see the same view of the network
so that they make consistent decisions when they're installing state in the data
plane. A final challenge that's also worth mentioning is security or robustness.
In particular, we want to make sure that the network continues to
function correctly in the event that
a controller replica fails or is compromised.